this is what happens when you keep
calling whites racist it turns on you
and then you have to make your argument
so watch this very interesting
most hated white students sues
historically black college for two
million dollars over racial
discrimination okay over racial it's not
something how could you say this is
racist no no it's just using your own
you know play it's a play out of your
playbook that you've been using uh a
white student Michael Newman who
attended Howard University's law school
from the fall semester of 2020 to
September of 2022 is using the
institution for racial discrimination
claiming that the school created a
hostile education environment Newman is
seeking two million dollars of monetary
damages for pain suffering emotional
anguish and damage to his reputation
Newman suffered depression anxiety and
Suicidal Thoughts as a result of public
ostracism vilification and humiliation
and the lawsuit claims that the student
at the schools responded with references
to his race gender sexual preference age
and personal preference personal
appearance after learning of a tweet
from new Newman's private Twitter
account that included a picture of a
slave with a caption but we don't know
what he did before the picture was taken
Newman's lawyers will try to prove this
School broke its contract with Newman a
student who attended on a scholarship
after a series of incidents and
accusations led to multiple review
panels and hearings that resulted in his
expulsion you know you know what happens
when you scream racism racism racism
racism racism constantly you water it
down for when somebody really is being
victimized yeah and then all of a sudden
you have a story like this and then you
have to argue well no racism doesn't
exist in this college no racism doesn't
exist in the NBA even though 70 African
Americans no racism doesn't exist in XYZ
then arguments get lost for example you
know that one meme that's gone viral and
a bunch by the way this meme was posted
on PVD podcast and Instagram immediately
immediately corrected it did you see
this meme that some of these memes they
put on pbd podcasts
uh uh well I I I I I gotta tell you the
guys that manage bbdp I manage Instagram
pbd but Peabody podcast managed by uh
our guy who's a beast uh he posted
something go up to see if it's all the
way at the top that's the one that's
hidden it's the one that's hidden with
warning go lower I'll warning that one
right there click on that one okay so
watch this uh see why look what this
meme says what it's okay with the fact
Checkers zoom in on the fact check oh
we'll we'll go to the fact Checkers
afterwards okay first let's read what
this meme is
can we see the meme it has to allow you
to see the meme it says see post on the
bottom look what this says I wonder why
there are no women transitioning to men
and trying to compete in men's sports
why is that so but they they just read
it one more time I wonder why there are
no women transitioning to men and trying
to compete in men's sports it's a lot
harder to do it's a lot harder to do of
course so Instagram fact checks it I go
back on it to read this fact check uh uh
go back to you how to write the question
why yeah and zoom in
the same false information was reviewed
by another fact checkered there are
there are there may be small differences
in a matter of fact it says fact check
it's not true
that no athletes assign female at Birth
transition then try to compete in men's
sports Elite stories okay wow tell me
how many stories of women became men
that try to compete in swimming in
wrestling in uh in Olympics in sprinting
tell me in in what in what that we read
about that you've actually read about
I'm sure it's happened I'm sure it's
happened but tell me when you've seen it
when it became a big story and day one
at the highest level that we had to see
where other men are like no no it's not
fair that you're transitioning when see
this this is the great thing about
debate and patience because what happens
with bad ideas if you're patient
just give it time eventually bad ideas
are going to be exposed on their own
without you even making an effort you
know when your kids sometimes say daddy
I'm I haven't gone through it yet but
I'm about to go through it my kids are
right now what they're they're 19 months
old you know six years old nine years
old 11 years old you know what phase I'm
in right now with my kids every parent
with their kids goes through three
phases phase number one they idolize you
okay phase number two they demonize you
yeah phase number three they humanize
you guess what phase I'm in with my kids
right now they idolize me love it's a
good phase they love me I don't do
anything wrong today right give it a
couple years give it a couple years
where they're gonna say what that you
have no clue what you're talking about
all you care about is capitalism do you
know the roots of capitalism
Thomas Jefferson and Ben
Jamin Russian George Washington and
April do you know what they did how
could you that how could you and I'm
gonna say honey son
uh Tico Dylan Santa bro whatever shown
you are I'm gonna be like okay bro
I'm patient okay in about 10 years
you're gonna realize how shitty of an
idea you're buying into right now I'm
patient don't worry the same thing that
a parent has to go through with their
kids is the same thing that the populace
has to go through in the media a certain
institution a political party a certain
sect decides to impose a dumb idea that
makes no sense and has zero common sense
and all you have to do is oh my God how
long is it going to take till you
realize how dumb of an idea this is I'm
patient I'm going to be right here
anyways it looks like you're trying to
show something so whatever you're trying
to do you made us read books Dad yeah
jerk I hate you I love it any thoughts
on this because before we go on you guys
are doing something with Rob Rob will
you was Adam sending you a story or no
okay I
it would this be a natural progression
to to talk about a transition to talk
about that Dilbert situation I was just
looking at this okay what was the
natural to what Dilbert situation that's
also has to do with racism did you read
that story go forward which one is that
that's the story about what happened
with the creator of Dilbert I mean since
we're on the topic of This Racist
cartoonist says a rebuke of Dilbert
Creator Scott Adams is long overdue so
here's the story so and by the way Elon
Musk laid into the late uh weighed in on
this so Elon Musk recently took to
Twitter to suggest that the U.S media is
now racist against white people and
Asian people as he seemingly defended
the Dilbert comic strip Creator Scott
Adams who made racist comments that led
to several newspapers dropping his
cartoon musk wrote for a very long time
the U.S media was racist against
non-white people now they're racist
against whites and Asians so same thing
happened with Elite colleges and high
schools in America maybe they can try
not being racist so here's what happens
Adam's comments came after erasmus's
poll revealed that 53 of black Americans
agreed with the statement it's okay to
be white
weird number in response
Adams posted an online video which he
said if nearly half of all blacks are
not okay with white people that's a hate
group
I don't want to have anything to do with
them and I would say based on the
current way things are going the best
advice I would give to white people is
get the hell away from black people
because there's no fixing this
Jesus Christ
that's a little that's a little too too
crazy about it there is a misconception
out there though that like
if you're a certain rate you can't be
racist towards white people and I'm
sorry bro if you hate a race and you're
always like I hate white people are the
you know you cracker dude that's that's
a racial that's a racial story you're
being racist either it's either be okay
with it yeah and have a thicker skin or
stop doing it on both sides exactly very
simple so guess guess what's believe it
or not
you know uh I'll tell you what oh go
ahead yeah I mean you have to understand
that either position you make and you
take you're going to contradict yourself
of course you're gonna end up being a
hypocrite and the American people are
gonna sit there and say yeah you're full
of [__] I'm not buying that's what's
gonna happen just you just have to be
patient with it anyways did you want to
say more things
um
it is sad or unfortunate to see this
number you know 53 of black people's in
this poll
uh agreed that it's okay to be white
sort of a shocking number but I think
his response and his approach is
actually pretty disgusting so he says
his answer is I don't have anything to
do with them and I would say based on
the current things they're going the
best advice is to give white people to
stay the hell away from black people
that's a racist piece of [__] if you ask
me maybe he actually is racist so for me
as I hear that because I'm more of a
natural synergist I would want to say
hey
you know I would say something if this
was my cartoon Dilbert I would say you
know the old uh Rodney King thing why
can't we all get along let's work on
this let's work on this together you
know I get that you've been wronged and
there's things that we need to address
but his approach is is the exact
opposite of way I would go not deal with
black people what does that even mean
yeah so to me that is uh
counterintuitive to what you're doing
but you do need a strong
African-American leader like Elon Musk
to step up in a moment like this yeah
good call yes I think the poll speaks
for itself and it's really unfortunate
um I you know to have any group of
people have that kind of a position and
the way he commentated because he moved
from just talking about a poll into
commentated and the way he commentated
was pretty bad however we've had a
recent guest and we've also seen the
lawsuit brought by Asian Americans
against Yale on discriminatory practices
on admissions so we are seeing uh
precedents out there where people are
saying hey when the pendulum swings the
other way you have to understand it you
you are you are making a bias against
somebody and a bias against anybody is
not good so so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]